last week the state of california sued
activision blizzard
the lawsuit alleges that one of the
biggest gaming publishers in the world
is discriminating against the women who
work there paying them less than men and
subjecting them to sexual harassment
this is a massive lawsuit that's
honestly pretty hard to read at times so
i'm gonna break down what's being
alleged here and what happens next
[Music]
all right folks before we get into this
video i just want to give you all a
content warning up front that this video
is going to get into some pretty
disturbing allegations
this lawsuit includes graphic
allegations of sexual harassment
sexual assault and suicide if these
topics trigger any sort of negative
response for you
you understandably do not have to keep
watching so
on july 20th the california department
of fair employment and housing or the
dfeh
sued activision blizzard the lawsuit
alleges that activision blizzard allowed
or
in some cases even encouraged a culture
to form where sexual harassment and
sexual assault occurred at work
on top of discrimination against women
with regards to fair pay
opportunities and firing bloomberg's
jason schreier first broke the story but
it's clear from reading the lawsuit that
the state of california
has been looking into activision
blizzard for a very long time
the lawsuit states that the dfeh has
been looking into blizzard entertainment
since
october 12 2018. they launched a
two-year investigation that eventually
brought in the activision side of the
company as well
the dfeh lists activision blizzard
blizzard entertainment activision
publishing
and 10 unnamed john does as their
defendants
essentially the dfvh believes that these
companies and these 10 unnamed
defendants are ultimately responsible
for the harassment and discrimination
that the women who worked at activision
and blizzard faced
so let's get into those allegations the
first is that women who worked at
activision blizzard were discriminated
against with regards to equal pay equal
opportunities
retaliation and many other aspects of
the job the dfea should list
multiple examples from their
investigation one woman alleges that she
was assigned a lower level role
and that she was denied equal pay to her
male colleagues
when she asked for a promotion she was
allegedly told to wait her turn
while the men who were hired after her
were promoted before she was
another woman alleges that she was
passed over for promotion in favor of
men who were friends with her unit head
the investigation found that one
supervisor allegedly delegated all of
his new responsibilities to women
and then he just played call of duty all
day that example also includes a note
that some supervisors allegedly
wouldn't talk to women at all and would
only get their information from male
subordinates
the dfeh's investigation also found that
women were allegedly paid less than men
in activision blizzard
starting from the moment they were hired
women hired by activision blizzard were
allegedly paid lower starting salaries
given less lucrative job assignments and
less
opportunities than their male
counterparts promotions also apparently
favored men with women receiving smaller
raises and being offered less stock and
incentive pay
the lawsuit states that women were
overwhelmingly put into lower positions
on the activision blizzard hierarchy
that they were paid
less and that they had to work harder
than their male counterparts to earn
their promotions
and sometimes they didn't even get those
promotions at all
the lawsuit includes allegations from a
woman who said she was passed up for a
promotion because her manager didn't
want to risk her getting pregnant and
preferring being a mother to her job
women were allegedly criticized for
leaving work to pick up their kids from
daycare and kicked out a lactation room
so other people could have meetings in
them
and according to the lawsuit women of
color faced even harsher discrimination
at times
one woman of color alleges that it took
her two years to be promoted to a
full-time role in activision blizzard
while men hired after her were promoted
much faster
meanwhile these men were allegedly just
playing games on the job while
supervisors would check in on this woman
if she did so much as take a break to go
for a walk
one woman of color alleges that she
asked for some time off
and in response was made to write a
one-page letter describing what she was
going to
do with that time off she later quit
so allegedly women were paid like [ __ ]
and treated unfairly by their
supervisors and male co-workers
but things got a lot worse the second
set of allegations in the lawsuit
concerns sexual harassment
and again things are gonna get really
[ __ ] up here
the dfeh says that the women they spoke
to likened working at activision
blizzard to working at a frat house
they alleged that there was a pattern of
sexual harassment and assault
with men regularly hitting on women
making sexual comments and
rape jokes and groping them all without
serious repercussions
women who worked on the world of
warcraft team allege that they were
regularly the subject of rape jokes
which supervisors knew about and either
didn't acknowledge or
outright encouraged the allegations
include breasts being touched without
consent a male supervisor telling a
subordinate to quote
by a prostitute when he gets in a bad
mood and
cube crawls which were allegedly what
happened when men would get
drunk and physically crawl through
women's cubicles to engage in
inappropriate behavior the dfe states
that women working at activision
blizzard had to constantly fend off
sexual comments and harassment
while the men would come into work hung
over the dfvh brings forward the story
of
one woman who worked for activation
blizzard who committed suicide while on
a business trip after she was allegedly
the target of sexual harassment at work
the dfeh says that some of her
co-workers believe
that other activision blizzard employees
were passing around pictures of her
vagina at a holiday party
she later killed herself on a business
trip with a male supervisor
who police found had brought a butt plug
and a lube on the trip
the dfeh states that complaints were
made to the human resources department
and to blizzard president j
alan brack but there were few if any
repercussions
in fact the dfeh notes that an internal
survey of activision blizzard employees
found that they didn't have much trust
for hr allegedly because hr didn't have
much sympathy for victims of sexual
harassment and abuse
the dfeh notes that hr was allegedly
close with
alleged abusers or that they otherwise
didn't keep confidential complaints
confidential which led to the women who
complained being retaliated against
this retaliation could take the form of
reduced work assignments
being transferred to another unit or
outright firing
and speaking of brac he comes up a lot
in this lawsuit but there's two
sections in particular that i want to
talk about the first is the story of a
woman who spoke to jay allen wrack in
2019
to tell him that people were leaving the
company on mass
because of the sexual harassment and
assault and the second is brac's
interactions with alex afrasiyabi
the former senior creative director of
world of warcraft
according to the lawsuit frasie abi was
a known harasser at the company during
events like blizzcon a frasier abi would
allegedly hit on women
call women derogatory names try to kiss
them and touch them without their
consent
and he allegedly did all of this in the
view of his supervisors who had to quote
pull him off of women these alleged
actions led to his room at blizzcon
allegedly being nicknamed the cosby
sweet
after alleged rapist bill cosby note
that the lawsuit says
crosby sweet and bill crosby but i
couldn't find any notoriously horrible
bill crosby's online
so i'm gonna assume this one was a typo
but to return to brac
the lawsuit notes that he had several
conversations with the frasier abi about
his drinking and telling him he was
getting quote
too friendly with women but the lawsuit
states that these conversations didn't
lead to much
more than a slap on the wrist even after
these conversations a frosty abi
allegedly continued
this behavior afrosyabi was very high up
in blizzard
he was one of the original members of
the wow team going all the way back to
vanilla in 2004.
wow fans noted that afros yabi changed
his employment status on linkedin last
year
quietly noting that he no longer worked
for blizzard this happened without the
sort of public announcement that many
longtime blizzard devs get when they
leave the company it's unclear if he was
fired or if he quit
but these allegations certainly paint
his departure in a different light
the lawsuit is seeking a ton of damages
though it doesn't list any specific
figures mostly the dfeh is looking for
activision blizzard to pay out damages
to the people affected
as well as relief which can take the
form of equal pay
incentive pay benefits and awards owed
to the women who worked there to be
clear
i don't know whether or not activision
blizzard is actually going to have to
pay out these damages
what i do know is that the dfeh is a
government organization accusing
activision blizzard of breaking the law
so they're under a ton of pressure here
news about the lawsuit breaking led to a
lot of people coming forward on social
media
some were sharing sympathy for the
victims of harassment and assault
while others were former activision
blizzard employees who
shared their own stories of being
harassed or assaulted and
more were former employees who stated
that they'd witnessed those actions
first hand
on reddit a user named empty bobbin who
says she was a former wow game master
wrote that she was harassed daily by her
manager while she was pregnant
including being written up for going to
the bathroom multiple times a day and
being told that every day might be the
day she'd be fired
on twitter former blizzard producer
stephanie crustick says that she was one
of the women who was harassed by a
frosty abbey
at blizzcon 2013. also on twitter former
blizzard employees share scarlett
also backed up the allegations in the
lawsuit there are dozens more people
coming forward now with their own
stories of harassment and allegations
about the culture at blizzard
or stating that they'd witnessed these
events but these allegations are not new
some people have been making these kinds
of claims about activision blizzard for
a long time
in 2016 the president of the academy of
interactive arts and sciences megan
scavio
tweeted that a frosty abbey called her
derogatory names which former wow team
member jennifer classing
backed up on twitter last week classing
says that every female identifying
person on the wow team was brought into
a meeting with brac the next day
who said that actions had been taken
against the frasiabhi
but classic notes that he remained the
creative director of wow for many years
after
and was given further opportunities and
you can look back even further to find
plenty of examples of blizzard employees
and even executives acting
inappropriately in public
here's the frosty abi speaking at a
blizzcon panel in 2010 sitting alongside
brac
and other higher-ups at blizzard i love
what you guys done with little crest
i love the fact that you have a lot of
very strong female characters
however i was wondering if we could have
some that don't look like they've
stepped out of
victoria's secrets catalog
[Applause]
what do you mean wait wait
which catalog would you like them to
step out
[Applause]
with felia and uh we want to vary our
female characters absolutely
um so yeah we'll pick different catalogs
[Music]
once last week's news broke the wow
forums were full of people saying they'd
canceled their subscription
and calling on others to do the same as
for what activision blizzard has to say
about this
well they're denying the allegations in
a statement provided to polygon they
write
the picture the dfeh paints is not the
blizzard workplace of today
over the past several years continuing
since the initial investigation started
we've made significant changes to
address company culture and reflect more
diversity within our leadership teams
activision blizzard statement accuses
the dfeh of painting an untrue or
distorted view of events
that happened at blizzard headquarters
they also accused the fah of not
participating in good faith negotiations
before going forward to litigation
notably the lawsuit states that the dfeh
had three mediation sessions with
activision blizzard in july
before the lawsuit was filed activision
blizzard finished a statement by writing
we are confident in our ability to
demonstrate our practices as an equal
opportunity employer that fosters a
supportive diverse and inclusive
workplace for our people
and we are committed to continuing this
effort in the years to come
it is a shame that the dfeh did not want
to engage with us on what they thought
they were seeing in their investigation
strangely the statement also includes a
bizarre section where activision
blizzard accuses the dfeh of
overstepping their boundaries
and that this kind of unaccountable
bureaucracy is leading companies to
believe the state of california
on friday axios reporter megan farrock
manesh tweeted out an email to
activision staff by their executive vp
of corporate affairs fran townsend
in which townsend doubled down on this
messaging calling the dfeh lawsuit a
distorted
and untrue picture of our company also
on friday bloomberg reporter jason
schreier reported that brax sent an
email out to staff regarding the lawsuit
in the email brack calls the allegations
in the lawsuit quote extremely troubling
and states that he has spent his entire
career fighting against quote bro
culture later that day kotaku's ethan
gatch reported that some blizzard
employees did not necessarily believe
brac
and were disappointed not to see any
plans to address the issues of the
company
on saturday wow's senior system designer
jeff hamilton tweeted that almost no
work is being done on a wow right now as
a result of this lawsuit
on sunday diablo co-creator chris metzen
tweeted out a similar statement
saying that he was shocked and disgusted
by what the lawsuit alleged and that he
was having trouble reconciling the
blizzard he knew with what had allegedly
happened under his watch
some have criticized these apologies for
ringing hollow because
if what this lawsuit alleges is true it
would have been very difficult for these
executives not to have known what was
happening to the women who worked for
them
and very easy for these men to have
changed the corporate culture and
finally on monday polygons nicole
carpenter reported that over 800 former
and current blizzard employees
signed a letter criticizing activision
blizzard's response to the lawsuit
the letter states our company executives
have claimed that actions will be taken
to protect us
but in the face of legal action and the
troubling official responses that
followed
we no longer trust that our leaders will
place employee safety above their own
interests to claim that this is a truly
meritless and irresponsible lawsuit
while
seeing so many current and former
employees speak out about their own
experiences regarding harassment and
abuse
is simply unacceptable as polygon
reports that the feh was previously
involved in a lawsuit against
riot in 2018 which came on the heels of
a kotaku investigation into riot games
that found that women were being
harassed and assaulted at work
in 2019 the los angeles times reported
that riot had to pay a 10 million dollar
settlement to the women who worked at
the company
in part due to the dfeh's lawsuit and
last year
stories broke from ubisoft offices all
around the world
of women who are experiencing
discrimination and sexual harassment at
work
this is all to say that it's not the
first time that a major game publisher
has been accused of fostering a toxic
workplace culture
and it's unlikely to be the last
[Music]
you